[Musica]
e allora io sono qui per raccontarvi un
pochettino delle connessioni quantistica
perché connessioni al cubo beh quello
che stiamo facendo adesso è utilizzare
anche se magari non vi sembra la
tecnologia quantistica perché solo
conoscendo le leggi della meccanica
quantistica possiamo avere un laser che
mi permette di puntare qui sopra
possiamo avere un calcolatore dei
transistor dei processori e così via
però la storia che voglio raccontare e
quella della seconda rivoluzione
quantistica perché oggi quello che noi
abbiamo le nostre bit nella nostra
società digitale
no vite sono zeri e uni accendo spengo
dei circuiti sono tanti elettroni che
vanno e vengono
sono tanti i fotoni che stanno una fibra
ottica che si muovono cos'è la seconda
rivoluzione quantistica per
raccontarvelo
voglio partire da una cosa che mi è
successa ormai vent'anni fa quando la
mia prima settimana ha finito il
dottorato il mio primo lavoro nelle
stati sbloccati prendo la bici esco
dalla cantina even in conto una
limousine nera
esce il dalai lama che qui e lui era
venuto in cantina non c'era solo la bici
ma c'era anche i laboratori del mio
collega rainer bluth è lì sua santità ha
potuto fare una cosa che a lui a scuola
a tutti noi a scuola e anche a mio
figlio
recentemente è stato insegnato che non è
possibile c'è stato a tutti ha detto non
è possibile vedere un singolo atomo
allora ti dicono sì c'è il microscopio
elettronico forse puoi avere una cosa in
diretta eccetera anche quel buco nero di
ieri dell'altro ieri non è veramente una
foto e una cosa ricostruita malato non
puoi fare la foto non lo vedi con gli
occhi allora nel laboratorio del mio
collega c'è una piccola trappola vuol
dire sono degli elettrodi di metallo
insomma dentro uno scatolotto vuoto con
un vetro sopra e tra lo scatolotto e il
mio occhio
c'è un microscopio e sono solo delle
lenti e io aspetto alcuni minuti e così
ha fatto anche sua santità dopo 34
minuti si abitua d'occhio al buio
appoggio l'occhio sullo cool aree e
dentro lo vedo il piccolo atomino
verdolino tutto solo in mezzo al buio è
però io lo vedo direttamente quello che
i padri fondatori della meccanica
quantistica pensavano fosse impossibile
dicevano più facile che fare un
esperimento con un singolo atomo è
allevare 1 dinosauro in uno zoo
come dire non succederà mai succede oggi
succede tutti i giorni succede una
montagna di laboratori in giro per il
mondo in giro per l'europa e anche in
giro per l'italia
l'italia anche molto avanti e su questo
o su questo campo di ricerca e questo
per me è il punto di partenza perché in
qualche modo costruire questo atomino è
una cosa che è fondamentalmente inutile
solo per la meraviglia solo per essere
affascinante se si vuole ma questo è la
base è il fondamento su cui si
sviluppano tutta una serie di cose che
vanno molto in là e questo è quello che
vorrei raccontarvi un pochettino un
passo indietro ho parlato prima della
tecnologia digitale di oggi questo è il
primo transistor che è stato costruito
nel 47 era una cosa grande così poi è
stato miniaturizzato miniaturizzato
miniaturizzato oggi abbiamo milio
milioni e miliardi di transistor su
ciascuno dei chip che ci portiamo dietro
in tasca i nostri telefoni e così via
la legge di moore è stata formulata più
di 50 anni fa e dice ogni paio d'anni
riusciamo a metterci né il doppio di
questi piccoli elementi per i circuiti
digitali sullo stesso spazio e ci costa
sempre uguale e qui abbiamo computer
sempre più potenti sempre più potenti e
questo lo vediamo qui ad esempio il
numero di transistor che ci sono a
seconda del tempo è cresciuto
enormemente da un migliaio a 20 miliardi
queste cose riportate tutti quanti in
tasca è però adesso questa cosa sta un
po finendo questa è di fatto la base per
tutte le tecnologie che utilizziamo per
tutti i nostri social media i vostri
social media facebook e twitter senza la
meccanica quantistica non sarebbero
possibili non so adesso si può discutere
sarebbe una cosa positiva o negativa
naturalmente ma comunque questo ci dica
chiaramente che ha un impatto molto
importante su quello che noi facciamo ma
adesso andare molto in là non è
possibile perché se lo rendo sempre più
piccolo alla fine arrivò all'atomo e
l'atomo come dicevano quelli che ha
lamentato da parola è quella che non si
può tagliare a metà più piccolo della
roma impossibile a un quanto più piccola
non c'è
allora cosa vuol dire che quando
facciamo le cose sempre più piccoli un
certo punto raggiungiamo un limite
questa crescita enorme a un certo punto
si romperà e si interromperà e noi
possiamo o disperarci oppure come se
fosse una grande industria di computer
oppure come pure anche alcune grandi
dossier di computer come microsoft ibm
intel google che stanno investendo
centinaia di milioni ciascuna ogni anno
e tra alcune settimane ci saranno ci
sarà un annuncio molto importante da
parte di google in questo senso dicono
quaderno è caduta non c'è più questa
crescita enorme
proviamo a inventarci qualche cosa di
nuovo questo è uno stimolo per
l'innovazione futura e questa è l'idea
delle tecnologie quantistiche allora qui
passiamo delle connessioni alla prima
potenza quelle normali quindi tutti i
giorni facebook
l'internet alle connessioni alla seconda
e connessioni da paura è una cosa che va
detto einstein einstein non credeva che
la meccanica quantistica fosse giusta
lui era convintissimo che fosse
sbagliate ha detto adesso io vi dimostro
che non può altro che essere sbagliata
perché perché prevede queste connessioni
assurde connessione da paura doveva
proprio detto
e qui c'è un disegnino attualmente non
vi faccio le formule ma la differenza
non è tantissima
qui ho un disegnino di un piccolo
sistema quantistico come quella torino
di prima in qualche modo dentro come
questo disegno di un cubo cioè sia la
figura la possibilità del cubo con la
faccia in su che la possibilità del cubo
con la faccia in giù ci sono tutte e due
quando lo guardo provate a guardarlo in
qualche modo non siete in grado di
vederlo nello stesso momento da una
parte dall'altra in qualche modo fa clic
avanti e indietro oppure vi si
stabilizza da una parte poi dovete
pensarci forse potrebbe essere anche
dall'altra
quando lo guardate cade in una delle due
possibilità se io ne ho più di uno di
questi è questa una figura che ho preso
a prestito da un collega premia dove nel
97 bill phillips quello che succede ne
ho due
in questi due anche lì ci sono le due
possibilità e quando li guardo anche lì
collassano ora faccia in giù o la faccia
in su ma il trucco qui è che non conosco
nessuno provate a fare questo esercizio
che riesca a vederli uno e giulio nel
suo nello stesso tempo o li vedete tutti
i due in giù o tutti e due in su ma in
sé diceva è assurdo questo perché nella
meccanica quantistica posso preparare
degli stati così
che se io poi questi due cubetti questi
due elettroni li separa loro sono sempre
connessi e anche se ho un elettrone qui
e l'altro e su alpha centauri
io ho subito guarda riguardo 1 e so
immediatamente che cosa succederà
lassù quando il mio collega lo va a
controllare istantaneamente e questa è
una cosa che serve per fare il
teletrasporto e questa sembra una
barzelletta
io posso dire che perché avete sentito
sicuramente dice teletrasporto su star
trek e io vi posso dire vi posso dire
tranquillamente che nessuna persona
verrà portata teletrasportato star trek
perché per essere trasportati bisogna
essere raffreddati molto noti pò verso
lo zero assoluto quindi non è facile
ricordarsene dopo che è successo ma
comunque comunque vi posso dire che
quella di star trek è molto più noioso
di quello vero quantistico perché in
star trek quello che succede
bing maps podi che significa trasmetti
me io so che cosa viene trasmesso e so
dove viene trasmesso ma il teletrasporto
quantistico non ha nessuna importanza
dov'è andato a finire quest'altro
quest'altro elettroni e fotoni potrebbe
essere su alpha centauri potrebbe essere
a milano lambrate potrebbe essere dove
volete voi
e comunque questa cosa funziona e viene
trasportato un messaggio segreto uno
stato non conosciuto perché non posso
sapere quale prima di aver misurato e
viene trasportato in una in un posto che
non conosciamo
e questo ancora una volta sembra una
cosa inutile
magari fantasiosa ma non tanto
realistica e magari neanche tanto
pratica è invece quello che possiamo
fare
e qui arriviamo alle connessioni al cubo
il terzo strato il terzo livello è
quello nel quale possiamo utilizzare
queste cose come tecnologia partono da
chiedersi il mani come ha fatto einstein
in maniera completamente filosofica se
la realtà esiste o non esiste ad esempio
ci sono stati esperimenti fatti da
colleghi che hanno realizzato questa
cosa di einstein chiedendosi se la
realtà esiste localmente o no la
risposta è la realtà localmente non
esiste adesso non abbiamo tempo serve un
altro top per per raccontare questa cosa
ma quello che interessa qui e che
possiamo usare queste cose perché perché
se io nel mio il mio stato lo uso per
trasmettere un messaggio
e se questo messaggio che può essere 01
può essere un beat di una lunga stringa
di un messaggio voglio trasmettere
se questo messaggio questo dato non c'è
prima che io lo misuri allora non può
essere intercettato da nessuno
semplicemente perché non c'è lo stato
la lettera lo zero l'uno appare solo
dopo che io ho fatto quella misura di
prima
e questo sembra una cosa
fantascientifica e invece ci sono ditte
che vi vendono dispositivi che fanno
queste cose c'è una ditta a ginevra che
è leader mondiale di questi temi si
chiama di quantic e non sto facendo
pubblicità a quella ditta sto dicendo
che qui in europa siamo riusciti
partendo da queste idee fondamentali
basilari a sviluppare delle tecnologie
che adesso veramente anno la supremazia
in giro per il mondo e a vienna il
collega styling è riuscito a fare per la
prima volta al teletrasporto lo stato a
cui siamo adesso è che è possibile
comprare questi dispositivi che banche e
governi stanno comprando per realizzare
comunicazioni si pone vi mando un fotone
nessuno può intercettarlo perché si
intercetta lo rovina lo distrugge se
qualcuno ci ha provato ci accorgiamo che
ha provato a misurarlo e quindi se
verifichiamo che nessuno ha intercettato
abbiamo una comunicazione sicura che
protegge i vostri dati che protegge la
vostra carta di credito su internet che
protegge i dati sensibili medici e così
via
e questa è una cosa che adesso succede
su una distanza di alcune centinaia di
chilometri e i colleghi che per la prima
volta hanno fatto questa è una figurina
di fantasia di una decina di anni fa
hanno realizzato questo per la prima
volta si sono accorti che magari si
poteva mandarlo sul satellite e hanno
provato a proporlo alle agenzie spaziali
europea la quale nei successivi 10 anni
ci ha dormito sopra e nel frattempo il
primo autore del lavoro che ha fatto
questo che ha proposto questa idea si
chiama già nuovi panna non è esattamente
tirolese come potete immaginare
lui è tornato a shanghai e dal
presidente xi ha ricevuto due miliardi
di dollari che gli hanno permesso di
realizzare questa cosa qui che un
satellite cinese che in questo momento è
in orbita e con il quale sono già state
fatte delle video chiamate
quantistiche sicure a miliardi che la
mattina distanza tra la cina e l'austria
e questa è una conseguenza del prendere
queste particelle singole strane
inaspettate con questi comportamenti che
non sono normali e utilizzarle per farci
qualcosa di tecnologico e questo è un
esempio
adesso un altro esempio che coinvolge
milano qui vicino a noi non lo vediamo
ancora ma se io uso un fotone io e lo
spedisco come sulla fibra ottica e
possiamo comunicare delle informazioni
se invece uso degli atomi posso usarli
per elaborare delle informazioni al
posto di un transistor prendo un atomo
quindi come ho detto prima lo faccio
sempre più piccolo più piccolo
alla fine arrivò il singolo atomo lui si
comporta anche lui l'atomo in questo
modo strano quantistico se ne ho tanti
di questi atomi loro sono nello stesso
momento in tutti i possibili stati tutte
le possibili combinazioni
quindi se io ho un computer quantistico
che riesce a manipolarli mantenendoli
belli freddi come abbiamo detto prima
quello che posso fare è o un certo
problema
pongo una domanda al mio computer ma
invece di porre una domanda alla volta e
ogni volta ottenere la risposta io posso
scrivere in questo computer quantistico
contemporanamente tutte le domande
possibili e ottenere tutte le risposte
nello stesso momento è come cercare in
un labirinto invece di andare pro qui
dopo provoli dopo provola andare nello
stesso tempo in tutti i possibili camini
del labirinto e voi capite che in un
giro solo io arrivo la soluzione e
questa è una potenza di calcolo enorme
che può servire per l'ottimizzazione i
sistemi di la volkswagen ha usato una un
simulatore quantistico per ottimizzare
il traffico dei taxi a pechino e questo
come ripeto spesso è una cosa che ha un
fisico quale sono io non verrebbe in
mente neanche sotto l'effetto di un
influsso molto imponente di vodka perché
è come dire al film di fisica non sta
pensare queste cose che pensiamo i
nostri giochi alle nostre cosina
studiato mini eccetera eccetera però poi
viene gente che dice ah aspetta che si
può fare qualcosa di utile settimana due
settimane fa mi ha chiamato da adidas
per sapere che cosa si può fare con un
simulatore quantistico arrivo tra quello
su cui l'altro un attimo allora qui c'è
un chip della intel con 7 17 49 bit
quantistici che lo hanno presentato
alla fiera dell'elettronica di las vegas
l'anno scorso quest'anno la ibm ha
presentato il primo calcolatore
quantistico commerciale potete comprare
velo è stato fatto a milano in modo che
fosse abbastanza legate questo non è uno
scherzo
la cosa esterna è stata realizzata a
milano in modo che avesse un sufficiente
impatto visivo e quindi penso che anche
qui a busto possiamo essere orgogliosi
di questo
ma quello che è rilevante è che queste
cose stanno veramente entrano nella
realtà dieci anni fa quando ho
cominciato a insegnare queste cose
diceva gli studenti si forse magari un
giorno ma insomma boss e invece oggi ci
sono
questo è forse per me la cosa più
incredibile di tutto in questo momento
ho altre due trasparenze che vi voglio
mostrare su altre due possibilità non è
la simulazione quantistica uso appunto
questi atom in i singoli li metto in una
struttura regolare come un cartone di
uova 1 a 1 e riesco a riprodurre il
comportamento di nuovi materiali magari
uno dei composti chimici li posso
utilizzare per sviluppare dei nuovi
sistemi chimici da nuove sostanze magari
di sostanze superconduttivi ad alta
temperatura con cui potrei fare delle
linee elettriche che non disperdano
elettricità e quindi subito avrei gratis
il 50 per cento in più di elettricità è
invece un altro esempio è 6 utilizzo dei
singoli elettroni li posso usare come
sensori posso mettere un singolo
elettrone vicino a un neurone e si
accorge se il singolo neurone si è
acceso si è spento in tempo reale la
bosch in germania sta creando un
progetto pilota per mettere sensori di
questo tipo su un casco che dovrebbe
aiutarci a leggere l'attività cerebrale
per ad esempio guidare un computer
oppure persone che non possono
comunicare per problemi neurologici
riuscire a comunicare con l'esterno per
diagnosi per la medicina
c'è una montagna di applicazioni
possibili
e questi sono i motivi per cui la
commissione europea ha deciso di mettere
i piedi questo programma molto grosso di
cui stiamo parlando prima e se ne sta
giungendo un altro per creare una ne
stiamo discutendo proprio in questi
giorni per creare una rete sicura di
comunicazione a livello europeo quindi
un altro miliardo di euro esattamente
per questa cosa per la protezione dei
dati di tutti noi c'è una grande numero
di
ricercatori coinvolti i dettagli non
sono importanti quello che è importante
è che non solo ci sono c'è una
connessione tra questi quattro canti che
mi ha fatto vedere prima alla
comunicazione la simulazione la
computazione e la sensoristica ma che
tutto quanto si appoggia su un fondale
una fondamenta fondamentale di scienza
di base perché queste cose sono
possibile su questo voglio tornare tra
un attimo soltanto se continuiamo a
chiederci a porsi le domande
fondamentali quelle che sembrano
completamente inutile e l'idea
l'obiettivo alla speranza che abbiamo è
di poter arrivare in qualche modo come
una missione di portare l'uomo sulla
luna ma qui vedete una punto una
bandiera di come abbiamo visto un attimo
fa di altri continenti che sono molto
avanti su questo tema e magari a nostra
speranza è di poter sostituire quelle
bandiere o accompagnarla con una
bandiera nostra io so che l'unione
europea non è sempre percepita magari
come la cosa più vicina ai cittadini ma
questo è sicuramente un esempio in cui
l'unione europea può fare veramente
qualcosa di forte per tutti noi per il
futuro delle nuove generazioni perché
appunto le fondamenta di questa cosa
sono esattamente vanno in questa
direzione il futuro il futuro anche
professionale non solo di servizi di
possibilità di possibilità tecnologiche
ma anche di posti di lavoro per le nuove
generazioni e questo mi permette di
arrivare di nuovo al fondamento delle
cose questa è una slide che potrebbe
sembrare stucchevole invece l'ho messa
su ho concluso la mia presentazione
avanti una dozzina di ministri
dell'unione europea
alcuni mesi fa ho affittato la fo pur di
via in ha parlato in 3d viene non vi
dico quanto mi è costato per fare
la giornata iniziale di questi progetti
che abbiamo appena cominciato e la mia
slide finale era questa riscatta
ricostruì una flash con la nave
ammiraglia è il punto fondamentale forse
l'unica cosa che mi piacerebbe che
ciascuno di noi si portasse a casa oggi
è questa
e questo ci collega appunto con le nuove
generazioni da qualche cosa che possiamo
fare tutti noi possiamo imparare da loro
nel seguente senso che non importa
quanto una cosa sembra complicata
misteriosa esoterica non importa neanche
quando una cosa sembra utile
quello che importa
se vogliamo avere non solo l'innovazione
di domani ma anche quella del giorno
dopo anche quella delle generazioni dopo
di non smettere mai di guardare la
realtà con curiosità con meraviglia
lasciandoci sorprendere lasciandosi
affascinare
grazie mille
[Applauso]